Hydrogen isotope gets plugged in place normal hydrogen. Yep. So that's
deuterium, double theatomic weight. So it's called heavy water. So this is back
to the deuterium question. It's called heavy water ketogenic diet depletes
deuterium. That's interesting because I am not read that. I'm not seeing anything
of that. I listened to I was actually on a seminar once listening to the president
of the company who who created the deuterium depletion technology. I think he's
from Sweden. I don't know. I think he's from Europe. I don't think he was from the United States.
Really, really interesting stuff though. So you can actually make your own deuterium
depleted water by taking your water, freezing it, and then I forgot the whole thing. You
could get slightly lower deuterium levels in your water by freezing it and then pouring
off the water. That's not quite frozen because deuterium depleted water will freeze at
a lower freezing point. And you keep doing that over and over till it just would be really
a pain to do. So.